muluzi alors donc pas de pessimisme
à mon avis ça marchera jamais non mais
ça c'est ce qu'il a fait pour lui une
part non et puis aussi ce qu'il a fait
avec souchon
il n'y a pas des chansons que vous avez
écrites pour souchon et que vous
regrettez de lui avoir donné à ce fumier
c'est non c'est non
alors non d'abord ça ça peut pas parce
que quand on est quand on part écrire
des chansons pour l'un ou pour l'autre
c'est justement pour l'un ou pour
l'autre et il ya assez peu de chansons
qu'on aurait pu chanter deux mois par
exemple qu'un aurait changé de noël sont
différents parce que les problèmes comme
l'un des bilans ces chansons sont pas du
tout il n'a pas du tout les mêmes
fantasmes que moi la même vision de la
vie que moi
en même temps on est certainement
complémentaires mais on va on va avoir
le même résultat mais je vais voir le
verre à moitié plein lui valent vide